(erschöpft:) Oh, AstraZeneca
Okay, so viel Verwirrung
und jetzt endlich wieder Klarheit.
Oder ... noch mehr Verwirrung?
Erst wurde der Impfstoff wegen
eventueller Nebenwirkungen gestoppt.
Dann hat gestern Abend die EMA,
die Europäische Zulassungsbehörde,
die Ergebnisse ihrer Untersuchungen
veröffentlicht, und jetzt -
soll es doch wieder weitergehen.
Was ist hier eigentlich los?
Was hat die EMA genau gesagt?
Und können sich wirklich alle
bedenkenlos mit AstraZeneca
impfen lassen?
Das klären wir jetzt,
los geht's.
(Lässiger Beat)
Ich will
mit etwas Superwichtigem anfangen,
dass in der öffentlichen Diskussion
leider etwas unter den Tisch fällt,
denn das, was gerade mit AstraZeneca
passiert ist,
kann mit jedem anderen Impfstoff
auch passieren.
Deswegen lasst uns bevor wir
zur EMA und so kommen,
erst mal ein paar Basics verstehen
zu Phase 4, also der Phase,
in der wir uns gerade befinden.
Wir haben uns in Europa gegen
Notzulassungen entschieden -
alle Coronaimpfstoffe durchlaufen
den normalen Zulassungsprozess.
Denn Sicherheit hat bei Impfstoffen
allerhöchste Priorität.
Aber wenn eine Nebenwirkung
in einem von 100.000
oder von einer Millionen Fälle
auftritt,
dann fällt das in der klinischen
Studie mit "nur" 10.000 Probanden
statistisch nicht auf.
Das heißt, Impfstoffe werden immer
mit einem gewissen
Restrisiko zugelassen.
Für eventuelle,
seltenere Nebenwirkungen
die sich erst
in der breiten Anwendung,
also nach der Zulassung
zeigen würden.
Und dieses Restrisiko kann,
also muss man in Kauf nehmen.
Denn noch mal:
In der statistischen Risikoabwägung
kommt man irgendwann an einen Punkt,
wo man klar mehr Schaden anrichtet,
wenn man einen Impfstoff zurückhält,
der schon an 10.000 getestet
sich als sicher erwiesen hat,
als wenn man den noch weiter testet,
nur um das bereits geringe Risiko
noch ein Stück mehr zu verringern.
Das Risiko steht ohnehin schon
in keinem Verhältnis
zu dem von Covid-19.
Was nicht heißt, dass seltenere
Nebenwirkungen egal sind.
Im Gegenteil: Deswegen gibt es ja
nach den klinischen Studien -
Phase 1, 2, und 3, noch die Phase 4,
in der befinden wir uns jetzt.
Und Phase 4 bedeutet, alles was nach
einer Impfung auftritt
und über eine normale Impfreaktion
hinausgeht,
muss dem Paul-Ehrlich-Institut
gemeldet werden.
Das machen Ärzte, das kann auch
jeder selbstständig machen,
zum Beispiel über dieses Formular.
Und diese Meldepflicht ist sogar
gesetzlich vorgeschrieben.
Nur deswegen, übrigens,
sind diese Sinusvenenthrombosen,
ich komm da gleich noch drauf zurück,
überhaupt erst aufgefallen.
Eben weil Auffälligkeiten
so sorgfältig beobachtet werden.
Okay, jetzt werden aber natürlich
nach Impfungen so oder so
unterschiedliche Dinge passieren.
Beispiel: 2019 starben rund 900
Menschen pro Tag
an Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen.
Darunter 120 Menschen pro Tag
an 'nem Herzinfarkt.
Das heißt,
sowas wird natürlich zufälligerweise
nach einer Impfung passieren.
Gerade bei unserer Impfstrategie
wo zuerst ältere geimpft werden,
die mehr Beschwerden oder eine höhere
Sterblichkeit haben.
Die Frage ist also nicht ob nach
einer Impfung Beschwerden auftreten,
denn das werden sie.
Sondern ob es häufiger passiert
als sonst.
Und wenn das der Fall ist,
dann ist das verdächtig.
Jetzt hatten wir einen Verdachtsfall.
In Deutschland zum Beispiel
sind sieben Fälle
einer Sinusvenenthrombose
aufgetreten.
Eine Sinusvenenthrombose
ist ein Blutgerinnsel
in der Hirnhaut.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit
der klassischen Thrombose,
die man vom Flugzeug kennt.
Diese Sinusvenenthrombosen
sind schwieriger zu behandeln,
und gefährlicher
als die normalen Thrombosen.
Sie sind selten, wie gesagt,
also insgesamt sind weniger
als 20 Fälle bekannt bisher.
Aber davon sind auch mindestens
sieben Menschen schon verstorben.
Und es sind ziemlich junge Menschen,
zwischen 20 und 50 Jahre alt.
In Deutschland kommen sieben Fälle
auf rund 1,6 Millionen geimpfte.
Das ist erst mal wenig.
Aber alle Fälle traten vier
bis 16 Tage nach der Impfung auf.
Und in diesem Zeitraum würde man nur
einen statt sieben Fälle erwarten.
Das heißt, es ist ganz richtig,
dass die Zulassungsbehörden,
also das Paul-Ehrlich-Institut
und die EMA
alles noch mal
genau überprüfen wollen.
Was man also verstehen muss, ist,
dass genau dafür Phase 4 da ist.
An der ganzen Sache
sieht man die Sorgfalt
und die hohe Priorisierung
der Impfstoffsicherheit.
Also alles,
was man immer versprochen kriegt,
nämlich: "Wir passen höllisch auf,
dass die Impfstoffe sicher sind."
Das wird hier umgesetzt.
Ob's notwendig war den Impfstoff ganz
auszusetzen, ist eine andere Frage.
Darauf kommen wir noch mal.
Aber was sagt die EMA?
In der Videobeschreibung verlinke
ich euch ein informatives Factsheet
vom Science Media Center, in dem
unter anderem beschrieben wird,
wie genau die Verdachtsfälle
untersucht wurden und werden.
Hier jetzt die Ergebnisse
dieser Untersuchung:
Erstens, die AstraZeneca-Impfung
zeigt kein erhöhtes Risiko,
für allgemeine Thrombosen.
Unter den Geimpften beobachtete man
sogar weniger Thrombosefälle
als man erwarten würde.
Und weil Covid-19 auch das Risiko
für Thrombosen erhöht,
geht man eher davon aus, dass die
Impfung mit dem Schutz vor Covid-19
das Thromboserisiko sogar senkt.
Zweitens, man beobachtet Fälle
einer speziellen Thromboseart,
oder einer speziellen Kombi, nämlich
diese Sinusvenenthrombosen
in Kombination
mit einem Mangel an Blutplättchen
und inneren Blutungen.
Das ist eher ungewöhnlich.
Diese seltenen Spezialfälle müssen
nicht mit der Impfung zusammenhängen.
Möglich ist es aber.
Das wird derzeit
noch weiter untersucht.
Anscheinend sind eher Jüngere
und eher Frauen betroffen.
Doch Alter und Geschlecht alleine
reichen noch nicht als Erklärung.
Dafür ist es zu selten.
Man kann derzeit nur spekulieren.
Möglicherweise erhöht
eine frühere, asymptomatische
Covid-19-Erkrankung das Risiko.
Möglicherweise ist das Risiko bei
Frauen die die Pille nehmen erhöht.
Möglicherweise spielen genetische
Prädispositionen eine Rolle,
oder Dinge wie Rauchen -
man weiß es derzeit noch nicht.
Übrigens: Auch alle anderen
zugelassenen Impfstoffe,
Biontech-Pfizer, Moderna
und auch Johnson & Johnson
werden jetzt auf diese
Nebenwirkungen untersucht.
Drittens, selbst wenn man
vorsichtshalber mal davon ausgeht,
dass diese Sinusvenenthrombosen eine
echte Nebenwirkung der Impfung sind.
Steht das Risiko in keinem Verhältnis
zu dem Risiko von Covid-19.
Derzeit sind es 18 Fälle
dieser Sinusvenenthrombosen.
Bei fast 20 Millionen geimpften.
Während täglich Tausende Menschen
an und mit Covid-19 sterben.
Deswegen betont die EMA,
dass der lebensrettende Nutzen
dieser Impfung
die Risiken für mögliche
Nebenwirkungen
ja, völlig in den Schatten stellt,
und kommt deswegen zu dem Fazit:
Wichtig ist jetzt eben,
dass verständlich und ausführlich
aufgeklärt wird
über die Nebenwirkungen.
Ähnlich, wie man bei einem Medikament
auch den Beipackzettel kennen sollte.
Und, dass Auffälligkeiten nach einer
Impfung weiterhin gemeldet werden.
Und hoffentlich kriegt man durch
diese erhöhte Aufmerksamkeit
auf diese seltenen Thrombosen
auch schneller neue Erkenntnisse.
Also, dass ein Verdacht kommuniziert
wird, richtig.
Dass dem Verdacht nachgegangen wird
und es geprüft wird, auch richtig.
Aber ob man während der Überprüfung
die Impfungen hätte aussetzen müssen,
darüber gehen auch in meinem Team
die Meinungen auseinander.
Lars fand es gut und richtig,
dass ausgesetzt wurde.
Man stelle sich vor, was los wäre,
wenn sich der Verdacht
bestätigt hätte.
Dann wäre das Vertrauen
erst recht hin,
hätte man Menschen trotz Verdacht
weiter gefährdet.
Jens fand das Aussetzen zu früh,
zu vorsichtig.
Vor allem angesichts
der aktuellen Pandemielage.
Fakt ist: Durchs Nichtimpfen schadet
man deutlich mehr Menschen
als durchs Impfen.
Melanie und ich fanden
beides vertretbar.
Aber in einer Sache
sind wir uns alle einig.
Das jetzt, nach der Untersuchung
der EMA und ihrem klaren Fazit,
die Impfungen
wieder aufgenommen werden.
Das finden wir
absolut richtig und gut.
Ja, würde ich.
Dasselbe sagen auch Lars,
Jens und Melanie.
Dafür gibt es
einen ganz rationalen Grund.
Selbst wenn wir davon ausgehen,
dass all diese Hirnthrombosefälle
eine echte Nebenwirkung
der Impfung sind.
Dann erhöht eine Impfung das Risiko
um fünf bis zehn Fälle pro Millionen.
Meanwhile liegt die Sterblichkeit
von Covid-19
in der entsprechenden Altersgruppe
bei der Größenordnung
von Tausend pro Millionen.
Das steht nach wie vor
in keinem Verhältnis.
Und wir reden nur über Sterblichkeit,
nicht noch über andere Folgen
wie Long-Covid.
Auch wenn ich zu gut verstehen kann,
dass so eine nüchterne Betrachtung
schwer fällt,
angesichts der chaotischen
Nachrichten rund um AstraZeneca.
Und nicht nur jetzt -
von der Wirksamkeit,
über die Zulassung verschiedener
Altersgruppen, ich kanns verstehen.
Ich kann nur an die Regierung,
an das Bundesgesundheitsministerium
und das Paul-Ehrlich-Institut
appellieren,
Bitte nehmt die berechtigten Sorgen
und Verunsicherungen
der Bevölkerung ernst.
Ich find's unmöglich,
so was wie das Aussetzen
von AstraZeneca zu droppen,
ohne ausführlichere Erklärungen
mitzuliefern.
Ja, es gab einen Tag später
dieses nützliche FAQ.
Aber sorry,
das ist in meinen Augen zu spät.
Wir wissen doch, wie schnell
so etwas hochkocht.
Wie so was durch alle Medien
und soziale Medien gejagt wird.
So was hätte
mit der ersten Pressekonferenz
mitkommuniziert werden müssen.
Es kann nicht sein, dass
Zeitungsartikel oder Twitterthreads,
ausführlichere Erklärungen liefern
als offizielle Stellen.
Die guten darunter
verlink ich euch unten.
Natürlich stoßen so News
neue Desinformationen an,
und Verschwörungsmythen.
Und natürlich auch ganz normale
Skepsis und Verunsicherung.
Das erschüttert das Vertrauen
in meinen Augen viel stärker,
als das Auftreten
seltener Nebenwirkungen.
Denn es ist ja alles
rational erklärbar.
Man muss es nur erklären.
Aufklärung ist eine der wichtigsten
Maßnahmen für diese Pandemie.
Das dürfen wir uns nicht verspielen.
Wenn euch das Video geholfen hat,
bitte teilt es mit euren Freunden.
Hier kommt ihr zu einem unserer
Lieblinksfunkkanäle: Psychologeek.
Und zu unserem letzten Impfvideo.
Wir sehen uns bald,
bleibt sicher.